headquarters after a night of waiting
the november matchups are set but one
candidate for governor isn't conceding
the eight news now i-team's david charns
here with the breakdown of the numbers
and what joey gilbert is saying on
social media david brian denise joey
gilbert standing right here during our
gubernatorial debate he lost the race to
clark county sheriff joe lombardi you
see here by about 10 points joe lombardo
doing very well here in clark county
carrying the county by more than 20
points even up here in washoe county
where joey gilbert is from gilbert
leading by just three points last night
in a facebook post he appeared to be
challenging the results saying in part i
smell a lawsuit now we reached out to
gilbert's campaign today and did not
hear back so we don't know if he will
request a recount if gilbert or any
other candidate decides to request a
recount here are the rules here in
nevada they are not automatically
triggered the candidate has three
working days from when the election is
certified statewide to request a recount
and unique to us they do have to pay the
cost of that recount so when we talk
about november it will be governor
sislek against sheriff lombardo let's
talk about the other big race here last
night former attorney general adam
laxalt the winner in the republican
nomination to run against democratic
senator catherine cortez-masto you see
here laxalt beating his opponent sam
brown by more than 20 points all that
red here shows just how strong laxalt
was here winning in every single county
except one here all the way north in
douglas county and sam brown only won by
one percentage point there so for the
race in november we're talking about
senator cortez masto against adam laxel
her campaign already out with an ad
blasting the results today so now more
money will flow into our state we're
going to see a lot more ads because both
democrats and republicans fighting for
these seats denise